JENIFER FOULKES: OK.
Welcome, everyone.
My name is Jenifer Austin
Foulkes, and I manage Google's
Ocean program.
And I'm here with Richard
Vevers, who's director of the
Catlin Seaview Survey, and
today, we're going to talk
about Underwater Street View.
To start off, I think it's
helpful to give a little bit
of background on our
Ocean program.
So it started over six years
ago, when Sylvia Earle, who's
a famous ocean explorer, was
at a conference in Spain
getting an award.
And she went on stage, and in
the audience was one of the
founders of Keyhole, which
became Google Earth.
And she said, John, I love
Google Earth, my grandsons fly
all around the planet, but you
should really call it Google
Dirt because you're
missing 3/4 of it.
And he laughed, and everybody
laughed, and then he had
Sylvia come and give a
tech talk at Google.
And that recruited many of us
to come together to work on
how you would add an explorable
ocean to Google Earth.
And we launched that four years
ago with Jimmy Buffett
and Al Gore.
And since then, we've worked
with many groups, like NOAA,
Scripps, Navy, [? Jebco ?]
to improve our
underwater map of the ocean.
And you can see at the very top
is San Francisco Bay, and
right off the coast is a canyon
called Monterey Bay
Canyon, that's deeper than
the Grand Canyon.
And what we spent the last
several years doing is
improving this map
of the ocean.
And that gives you a sense--
anyone can now hold the ocean
in your hands, and our products,
and Google Earth for
Android phones, tablets.
But what you couldn't do, until
the end of last year, is
actually see what it looks
like underwater.
And this has been what Richard
and I have been working
together on, which we're really
excited to talk to you
about today.
And I'm going to start off with
just a short video that
we featured at our launch
that introduces.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JENIFER FOULKES: So that's
what we launched at
the end of last year.
And our goal is, really, to make
all of our Maps products
more comprehensive with
more ocean data.
This is the blog post
for our launch.
The turtle was seen
everywhere.
And our goal was really to take
you from your home in
Street View and Google Maps
to a turtle's home.
And I'm going to show
you how it looks in
our new Maps product.
Click on the little See Inside,
it takes you into
Street View, and you can
visit the turtle.
You can go halfway in, halfway
out of the water.
You can visit the Heron
Island Resort.
You can see where you might like
to be sitting, reading a
book, testing out your next
vacation, looking out at the
beautiful Great Barrier Reef.
Lying underwater and visiting
all the marine
life that lives there.
So we're really excited
about this.
We're excited about adding
underwater to
our Street View product.
And we've released about
six places so far.
One in the Philippines, three in
the Great Barrier Reef, and
two in Hawaii.
And I've actually snorkeled
myself at the Hanauma Bay
location in Oahu and seen
changes over the last only six
years that are pretty
dramatic.
And all the more reason why we
need to capture imagery right
now, and bring it to the
rest of the world.
So as I've heard from many
scientists, from Sylvia Earle--
she has seen in her lifetime,
50 years of diving--
most of the big fish are gone.
Half of coral reefs are gone.
The oceans are warmer.
They're more acidic.
And coral reef decline
is expected to
continue in our lifetime.
And the chief scientist on
Richard's project, Dr. Ove
Hoegh-Guldberg from the
University of Queensland,
published a paper in "Science"
10 years ago showing the
effects of ocean
acidification.
So you see a healthy
reef on the left.
In the middle, the atmospheric
carbon dioxide
is at a higher level.
The ocean's become more acidic,
and eventually the
corals die.
And this last figure from his
"Science" article shows, in
blue, the areas in the world--
this is a world map--
where coral reefs can
actually live.
And as the atmospheric CO2
increases, as noted by the
little white number, the
areas in blue shrink.
So the areas where corals can
live are rapidly declining.
And so it's all the more reason
why we're so excited
that Richard is using our
products to feature this
beautiful underwater imagery
to really ignite
excitement in the world.
And with that, I'm going to
turn it over to Richard.
RICHARD VEVERS: Thank
you, Jenifer.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD VEVERS: There's a very
serious side to this project,
but there's also an amazingly
fun side to the project, as
you could probably get an idea
from the underwater scooters
that we were driving
in that video.
For me, if you like a challenge,
this is arguably
the most exciting time to be
in ocean conservation.
What happens here, in the next
10 years, is likely to affect
our oceans for the next
10,000 years.
So it is an immense challenge
that we've got ahead of us.
But really, it's through
technology that we can find
the solutions.
Now, this is an image
that we took of the
Great Barrier Reef.
It's just one reef on the
We took this image about two
months ago, during our major
survey that we were
doing there.
And it just shows the kind of
devastation that is happening.
The Great Barrier Reef has lost
53% of its corals over
the last 30 years alone.
And this kind of information
just isn't publicly out there.
And it's because there haven't
been the communication tools
up until now, really, of
communicating this.
So it's why Street View, and
getting this kind of imagery
out there, is critically
important, as well as getting
the highly engaging content
as you saw in the videos.
Now, we set up our project,
really, to reveal the
reefs of the world.
Now, the biggest single issue
facing our oceans, currently,
is the fact that they're out
of sight, and out of mind.
Really, the issue is
that people can't--
well, don't want to protect
anything that they can't see.
And it's vital that we reveal
the oceans to the world, which
is why we set up our
not-for-profit organization
about three years ago.
99.9% of people on the planet do
not dive, and they probably
never will.
But there's no reason
why we can't take
them virtual diving.
And this is really why we
set up the organization.
There's no excuse, anymore,
for not having the oceans
accessible to everyone
with internet access.
If Google can do this in the
terrestrial environment, we
thought there's absolutely no
reason why we shouldn't be
doing this underwater.
So we went about designing a
camera that could do this.
Now, the cameras for underwater
work very
differently from
cameras above.
We couldn't use just the
existing Street View camera
and take that underwater.
We had to use much, much
wider-angle lenses to work in
low-visibility conditions.
Obviously, we had to replace
the car with an underwater
scooter, but we still
got the same driver.
The way we've worked the camera
is-- you've got three
cameras at the front, which are
all firing simultaneously.
And as we travel along, we
take a shot every three
seconds at about 2 meters
above the ocean floor.
Now, when you're on expedition,
you're going to
have flooded cameras.
So we wanted to design a camera
that could work, that
we didn't have to open while
we're on expedition because
that's when you're going
to have the problems.
So we actually worked with a
system where we've got an
underwater tablet, which you
can see just to the back of
the scooter there, that
operates the cameras.
It controls the ISOs, and the
speed, so we can make
adjustments as we're motoring
along the reef.
Now, typically on a dive we'll
cover 2 kilometers and we'll
take 3,000 images, which
are then stitched to
create 1,000 panoramas.
And these can all be uploaded.
At the moment, we've been
focusing on the most engaging
content, but it really is a case
of trying to reveal as
much as we possibly can.
Now, this just gives you
an indication of
three of the shots.
We've got two pointing slightly
up, to the left and
to the right, and one pointing
directly down.
Now, the reason why we went
for this configuration is
because to monitor reefs, you
need that downward-facing
image because that's the one
that has been traditionally
used in the past, a
downward-facing shot of reefs
and other ocean environments.
So we set up the configuration
in this format, and then
pointed the camera
slightly forward.
So we've got a black
spot behind
where the diver's hidden.
And we have to stitch that
for the end result.
Now, the end result is to
create this-- this is an
equi-rectangular image.
But when you search for
panoramic images underwater,
on the internet, there are
very, very few out there.
And especially a
full 360 image.
This suddenly communicates, in
a way that's never been done
before, exactly what that
environment is.
A scientist, or anybody, can
look at that environment and
see what the structure's like,
how healthy it is.
But more importantly, we can
also look at it and monitor it
for change.
Now, Jenifer is going to talk
through some of the
challenges we had.
Once we'd collected this
imagery, it was then a case of
trying to get it into
Street View.
And there's an amazing tool that
allowed us to do this.
JENIFER FOULKES: Yes.
So, thanks, Richard.
So we basically had worked with
Richard to help him use
our Business Photos tool
to upload his imagery.
And so anyone who joins our
Business Photography program,
you can upload your own
panoramic imagery, as this
garden center in New
York has done.
I think once you have that
panoramic imagery in Street
View, you can then use the
Street View API to embed that
content on your own website.
And you can see we've done
that here with our Maps
gallery at
maps.google.com/ocean.
Here's some of the code from
our developers' site that
shows you how you can do this.
And another partner of
Richard's, TerraMar Project,
which is another non-profit,
has embedded Richard's
beautiful imagery in a sort of
gallery context using the
Street View API on their
own website,
for educational purposes.
For students and teachers to go
there and get quick access
to that imagery.
RICHARD VEVERS: Now, the Catlin
Seaview Survey isn't
really just about revealing
the oceans to the world,
especially coral reefs.
But I mean, that's half
of the story.
The rest of the story is about
creating a scientific baseline
with which to monitor change.
Now, it was when we initially
showed the first images that
we were capturing to one of the
world's leading coral reef
scientists.
He saw the potential
of this imagery.
Because traditionally, they've
been sending a diver down and
doing a 50-meter dive, taking
photographs of the sea floor.
And that was the way of
monitoring these environments.
Suddenly, we have a tool for
doing 2 kilometers at a time,
and capturing the full
360 environment.
And it allowed you to see
exactly what was going on in
that entire environment.
So we set about establishing a
strict scientific protocol for
all our data capture.
And that's what we have been
doing over the last five
months on the Great Barrier
Reef, visiting
32 different reefs.
And now we've expanded the
project over to pilots in the
Caribbean and other areas.
Now, all these images are
going to be made freely
available for scientists to
analyze, and we'll come along
on to some of the analysis
in a minute.
And we're launching the Catlin
Global Reef Record later on
this year, which will have all
of the images, and not just
the most engaging images,
available for scientists to
study, as well as the public
to monitor the change.
Now, image analysis is critical
to this project.
We currently have in the region
of 150,000 images that
we've taken over the last five
months, and this figure is
going to grow exponentially
as we expand the project.
Now, this is just a section
of one of the
downward-facing images.
But Scripps, over here in the
US, has developed some amazing
image recognition technology
that will allow us to identify
species of corals on reefs.
And the data that we collected
from the Great Barrier Reef is
currently being processed
as we speak.
But currently, this is
restricted to the
downward-facing camera.
We currently have no way
of auto-analyzing
the rest of the 360.
And that's something we
desperately need to develop so
we can get the full picture.
We're also working, just back
on the science, on the 3D
modelling of the reef.
We've got stereo cameras which
are adding an extra layer of
data that hopefully, when we
can combine with satellite
data, will provide us with
hugely powerful planning tools
for global reefs.
Now, as I said, this project
is 50% science and 50%
communication and engagement.
And really, that's what sets
this project apart from most
projects, is this focus on the
community and the engagement.
There's really very little point
in doing science if it's
only getting out to a few
hundred people, especially not
to the public, and not
to the policymakers.
And this is where the
collaboration with Google is
absolutely vital to this project
because, instead of
these images being seen by a few
hundreds or even thousands
of people, we're getting
out to tens, or even
hundreds, of millions.
Now we've got over
3 million people
following us on Google+.
We do our regular
photo spheres.
We've got some daily updates
from the field.
We've literally just come off
an expedition at the moment.
And we do these daily updates
while we're out there, and
it's a hugely powerful tool,
especially when you use some
of the other features
of Google+.
We've been doing a lot of fun,
if slightly stressful,
underwater Hangouts, patching
in live to conferences from
underwater.
And the one on the left-hand
side was one we did--
it was over at our Monterey
launch, which unfortunately
was middle of the night for us
on the Great Barrier Reef.
But fortunately, a turtle turned
up halfway through the
show, which made for
added interest.
But again, this is an incredible
tool that we
haven't even scratched the
surface of the potential.
If we can get this out to
schools, for example, and
engage schoolchildren all over
the world with people that are
scientists underwater carrying
out the surveys, it's just an
amazing tool.
Also, the immersive
photo spheres--
I don't know whether you want to
show one, probably that we
loaded yesterday--
is a great way of just having
hero images that can really
capture an environment,
a whole area,
just in a single image.
This is one that we took--
I don't know whether I can
scroll around-- of a wreck in
Aruba, about three weeks ago.
But you're starting
to get the idea.
And some of our divers
on the survey.
And we'll be posting a lot more
of these photo spheres.
And Jenifer is going to
talk a little bit
more about photo spheres.
JENIFER FOULKES: So my colleague
Evan has been
driving the creation of this
ability to take 360s from the
Android phone.
And when you take a 360, you can
actually then upload, and
share that, to Google Maps.
And I'm particularly excited
because I just discovered that
there's actually an underwater
case for the Nexus 4, and I
will be diving in a couple
weeks in Bali to do some
testing of collecting my own
underwater photo spheres.
So I'm very excited
about that.
And after you upload them to
Maps, then you can also share
them on your own website and
embed them for whatever travel
or communication interest
you have.
RICHARD VEVERS: Yes, we have
been cheating slightly with
photo spheres at the moment,
using our SV2 camera, rather
than the Android, but we will
be taking a lot more Android
ones coming up soon.
Now, as we said, there's
very much a serious
side to this project.
Over the next three years,
we're planning to try and
capture a baseline for the
coral reefs of the world.
So we are focusing on the
Americas this year.
Then we're off to Asia, and the
Coral Triangle, which is
really the epicenter of
coral reefs worldwide.
And then we're off to the
Indian Ocean, right
up to the Red Sea.
So hopefully within the next
three years you'll be able to
go diving virtually anywhere
in the world.
Now, the decline is so rapid,
of coral reefs, that we feel
this is very much a
race against time.
And we want to go out there to
record and reveal coral reefs,
so that the change
can be monitored.
And we can look for areas of
resilience and work out what
are the critical areas
to protect.
And that is what this project
is all about.
Now, we need more developers.
We've had some amazing support
from the developers that have
been involved in the project,
from developing the apps to
control the cameras to really
looking at the technology for
the image recognition
to so many different
aspects of this project--
the stitching technology,
et cetera.
Technology very much is
the solution here.
It's the only way that we can
communicate to enough people
around the planet about what is
going on and carry out the
science that's required in
the required time frame.
There are three specific
areas that we need
to be focusing on.
The first of these areas is
engaging as many people on the
planet to help us in the
gathering of the data.
Now, we've got our SV2 cameras,
which are going to be
limited to the number of sites
that we can cover.
Now, if it was possible to
engage the 10 million divers
around the planet, using their
existing technology with
simple housings to create
baselines of their own, or go
back and visit our baselines and
monitor change, and notify
us of that change, we would have
a hugely powerful tool.
And this is something that we
very much want to focus on
over the next 12 months.
The second area is one that
I mentioned earlier.
And that is the image
recognition.
Once we've collected the data,
we need to be able to analyze
it, and analyze it quickly.
With potentially millions of
images, we need to develop the
software to look at the
full 360 and find
ways of doing that.
Now, this can be through just
development of the image
recognition, or we can engage
citizen scientists.
Now, because of the number of
people that we can talk to
through this project, thanks
to the collaboration with
Google, if we can collectively
bring the citizen scientists
together to start analyzing
these images and develop ways
of educating the computers
through that analysis, again,
that will be a hugely
powerful tool.
And a great way of engaging
people globally.
The third area is very much on
the engagement side of things.
How do we use this imagery in
the best possible way to
engage people?
Whether it's virtual experiences
in exhibitions,
it's headsets, it's just
any way of engaging.
We have amazing, engaging
content, but we need to
communicate it to as many people
around the planet as we
possibly can.
And that's what we're looking
for help for.
What we need, really,
is the developers.
And it's really developers and
the technology that are going
to provide the solutions
to this.
If you are interested in
getting involved in the
project, I'll be at the stand
where we've got the camera on
display at the Google
Maps area.
Or you can contact us through
the Google+ page, at Catlin
Seaview Survey.
Or also just contact
us through the
catlinseaviewsurvey.com.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
JENIFER FOULKES: And I'd just
like to also conclude that
this project wouldn't have
been possible without my
colleague Steve Silverman at
Google, who has helped me
manage this.
So thanks to Steve.
Yeah, so if there are any
questions about this project,
use the mic, or raise your
hand, and I'll repeat it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Daniel.
I have a couple different
questions.
One is, you said it takes a shot
every three seconds and
you do 2 kilometers on a run.
What would limit you
to 2 kilometers?
That's only about six
minutes, right?
RICHARD VEVERS: Sorry.
No, we're actually--
because it's an underwater
environment, you're going
along very slowly.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RICHARD VEVERS: So typically,
we'll cover 2 kilometers in
about 40 to 45 minutes.
We restrict that because of
the battery life of the
underwater scooter, and
also just keeping
within safety protocols.
The idea is if we could develop
the AUV version, in
the same way that we've got cars
that don't need drivers,
we can go off for a 12-hour run,
and get a lot more data.
So that's, again, something
the we're working on.
AUDIENCE: How many cameras
do you have?
RICHARD VEVERS: Four,
of which two have
never been in the water.
One of them's on the stand.
So it is a very young project.
We only launched it back in
September last year, and we're
developing it as fast
as we possibly can.
AUDIENCE: Do you have plans
to get more cameras?
Or is it a financial, or--
RICHARD VEVERS: It's
a financial
restriction, at the moment.
The more cameras
that we have--
the idea is to be able
to bring third-party
organizations, so people like
NOAA, and other organizations
who have skilled divers, that
can carry out the data
collection for us if we can
provide them with the tools.
So yes, if there was a way of
getting more cameras, yes, we
would be wanting it.
AUDIENCE: How much
is a camera?
RICHARD VEVERS: The cameras--
it's around the $50,000
a piece mark.
AUDIENCE: US?
RICHARD VEVERS: US.
AUDIENCE: One question
to the Google side.
Is there any business
case in it?
JENIFER FOULKES: I think our
motivation in this has been
making our maps more
comprehensive.
And I think as you may have seen
in the keynote, there are
a lot of references to it.
I think it's very powerful and
excites the imagination about
what could be possible.
So I think, from my motivation,
it's been very
inspired by Sylvia.
With knowing, comes caring.
With caring, there's hope.
AUDIENCE: So there are no ads
placed, or something.
JENIFER FOULKES: Right now--
I mean, I don't have a crystal
ball, but no, that's not my
current plans with it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is David.
Do you capture other data like
temperature, and acidity, or
do you correlate with
satellite data?
RICHARD VEVERS: Yes, a lot of
the data that we're capturing
is related to the image data.
So depth loggers, et cetera.
Tilts and that.
But we're also doing
temperature.
We're collecting less of the
other data at the moment
because we're not in
environments long enough for
that data to be useful.
We're looking to leave long term
monitoring data in sites
to create sites that we go back
and revisit over time.
But that's something that we
need to add to the project.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned earlier that
you're thinking about doing an
autonomous camera?
Is that about right,
what you said?
RICHARD VEVERS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do you plan on
getting over the problems with
GPS signals and just other RF
frequencies underwater?
RICHARD VEVERS: To be honest,
I'm probably not the person to
ask about that.
But we've been working with the
University of Sydney, who
has developed an AUV that is
capable of hugging the
substrate 2 meters above the
substrate, and it will go for
12 hours at a time.
That's the kind of vehicle that
is perfect for this kind
of surveying.
And they've managed to work
out a very accurate way of
getting the GPS locations
because it's currently being
used for just that
single downward
monitoring of the substrate.
We're on full 360.
So we know the technology is
there, it's just a case of
getting it to work with our
current camera technology.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I work in a science museum, the
Lawrence Hall of Science
at Berkeley.
And this is more of a question
for Google because the project
I'm working on is stereoscopic
3D visualizations of lake
ecosystems.
So are there any plans of doing
a Street View-- and the
lake that we're doing
is Lake Tahoe.
So it's to empower people to
look at the dynamic and nature
of our freshwater ecosystems.
And I can actually see a
business case for doing a Lake
Tahoe underwater Street View.
Have you guys considered
freshwater ecosystems?
Because you're sea, but--
RICHARD VEVERS: Yeah.
JENIFER FOULKES: Yeah.
So primarily, we've been in the
beginning of this project,
so we've primarily been working
with Richard and the
Catlin Seaview.
But I would imagine, in the
future, as they get more
cameras, they could potentially
loan one to
somebody who wanted to do those
sorts of lake collects.
And there should be no problem
featuring it in that Business
Photos tool, just as they've
featured their imagery.
So in theory, it's
possible today.
AUDIENCE: Wonderful.
Thank you.
RICHARD VEVERS: Yes, we've
already started testing in
other environments.
Right down from Sydney Harbor,
through to mangrove areas.
A lot of the restrictions are
down to visibility, and making
sure you're getting the best
possible visibility.
But we're also looking at other
low-light cameras that
will really maximize the imagery
that we get back, so
it's of scientific use and also
it's highly engaging.
Because we need to be highly
engaging for it to get the
right messages out.
AUDIENCE: That's one reason why
I picked Tahoe, because
it's so blue.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I was wondering
how accurate your GPS
information is.
And if you're able to tie the
locations of the images to
navigational map datum that
are more from a vessel
navigation standpoint.
RICHARD VEVERS: Yes.
I mean, currently we've been
using the standard scientific
protocol, which is trailing,
because we're
in 8 meters of water.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RICHARD VEVERS: We can
trail a buoy behind
us at a fixed distance.
So that's how we're gathering
all of the data currently, and
obviously we can match that up
with other data sources.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: My question is mostly
with the specification
of your vehicle.
Like how long is the
battery life?
And how much is the storage?
And how often do you have
to replace the storage?
And get a new--
RICHARD VEVERS: A typical day
for us is we'll set out very
early on in the morning,
and we'll plan to do
three dives in a day.
You do two dives back-to-back
from a boat, and we change the
batteries of the scooters
over after each dive.
But the rest of the batteries
in the cameras, for example,
the orb unscrews off, and we
charge that up overnight,
download the data, clear the
cards, and then we're ready to
go the following morning.
And that will do us the
full three dives.
AUDIENCE: So each dive
is like 30 minutes?
RICHARD VEVERS: Each dive is
normally an hour by the time
we get down, carry out the
transact, and then get up to
the surface again.
AUDIENCE: So in each cycle, how
much data do you collect?
RICHARD VEVERS: Well, it will
be normally about 3,000 to
4,000 images per camera.
AUDIENCE: OK.
All right.
Thanks.
JENIFER FOULKES: Great.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD VEVERS: Thank you.